اذا بعد هذا التقرير لعمر حلبي من جنديرس
في ريفي حلب معنا لانا من كهرمان مراش
مدير مكتب الجزيره عبد العظيم محمد كهربان
مراش كانت مركز الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا
وكذلك انتقل الى سوريا اليوم مركز المسح
الجيولوجي الامريكيه يتحدث عن هزه جديده
بقوه خمس درجات على مقياس ريختر عبد
العظيم يعني هل شعرتم بهذه الهزه الجديده
وما مدى خطوره الوضع هناك
نعم ايمان يعني الوضع خطر جدا واي هزه
ارتداديه تعني مزيد من المباني
ستسقط لان معظم المباني في هذه المنطقه هي
عائله للسقوط
ومتصدعه والسلطات
المحليه والسلطات في انقره تحذر الناس من
الرجوع الى هذه المباني لانها ممكن تسقط
في اي لحظه من غير
الزلزال ممكن تسقط كيف اذا ما حصل هناك
هزه ارتداديه
ستعني مزيد من الدمار في هذه المنطقه لم
نشعر نحن تقريبا منذ ثلاث ساعات او اكثر
في هذه المنطقه لم نشعر ربما في
بازارجيك التي هي مركز الزلزال الرئيسي
الذي تبعد حوالي عشره كيلو متر من المكان
الذي نتواجد فيه وهي بلده صغيره
تابعه لمدينه محافظه كهرمان مرش نحن الان
في المركز هذا المركز فيه عمليات الانقاذ
هذا المربع السكني الذي نتواجد فيه كبير
جدا هناك ما لا يقل عن عشر بنايات سقطت في
هذا المكان والبحث لا يزال جاري قبل ان
نتحدث معكم بدقائق تم اخراج طفله صغيره من
هذا المكان الذي نتواجد فيه حيث سمع
الاهالي اصوات توجهت فرق الانقاذ الى هذا
المكان
شاهدنا اخراج طفله صغيره عمرها عشر سنوات
هذه عمرها عفوا 14 سنه كنت اسمعهم وهم
ينادون على هذه الطفله اسمها ايبك صاروا
ينادون عليها بدات تتحرك ثم بدات تتحدث
معهم
قليلا قليلا اخرجوها الان اذا تشاهدون في
الصوره
المسؤول عن عمليات الانقاذ طلبه اطفاء
الاليات حتى
يبداون بالمناداه على الذين يعتقد تواجدهم
في هذه تحت هذه الانقاض وكما علمنا ان
التواجد الان اخبرنا الاهالي انهم
يوساندون عمليه فرق الانقاذ في هذه
المنطقه
باعتبار ان الزلزال حدث في الساعه الرابعه
وعشرين دقيقه فجر يوم امس
ومعظم الساكنين في هذه البنايات كانوا في
غرف النوم الاهالي من اصحاب هذه البنايه
الذين نجوا من
الموت في هذه المكان واخرجوا يحاولون
المساعده في الاستدلال على غرف النوم في
توقع اين تتواجد غرف النوم من بقيه الغرف
للوصول الاختصار الطريق على فرق الانقاذ
التي تتواجد في هذا المكان وبالفعل في هذا
المكان حتى الان تم اخراج في هذه النقطه
التي نشاهد فيها المسعفين تم اخراج خمس
اشخاص من بينهم
اطفال
الطفله التي خرجت من هذا المكان ونقلها
رجال الاسعاف الى سياره
الاسعاف
انا شاهدتها وسمعت صوتها وهي تنادي على
امها ماما ماما
تبحث عن امها بين المتواجدين وامها للاسف
ليست موجوده
مشهد كان مؤثر جدا
الطفله لا تدرك ما يحصل في محيطها كانت
في حاله ذهول في حاله الرعب من المشهد هي
منذ يوم امس بين الانقاذ واحد
الجيران الذين كان يبحث عن ذويه في
المنطقه هو من سمع صوتها وبدا يصرخ على
فرق الانقاذ جاءت الى هذا المكان
وبالفعل وجدوها الان يتوقعون ان بقيه
افراد عائلتها ربما يكونون لا يزالوا في
المكان في نفس المكان الذي هي كانت تتواجد
فيه ويعتقدون انهم بما انهم وصلوا الى هذه
الطفله انهم يستطيعون الوصول الى
بقيه افراد
العائله هناك فرق انقاذ تركيا وفرق انقاذ
من اذربيجان
وجد في هذا المكان للمساعده في اخراج
اخراج ناجين من تحت الانقاذ نحن نشعر معهم
ايضا ومعكم ايضا عبد العظيم وانتم تغطون
هذه الاهوال كان الله في عونهم جميعا ورحم
من قضى منهم